the Eritrean capital Asmara
a city of tidy streets and welcoming
cafes dotted with impressive
architecture there on mistakable signs
of the country's economic woes and yet
ever since the peace deal with
neighboring Ethiopia in Asmara hope is
in the air this peace will bring
especially Eritrea to to concentrate on
other issues like developments in every
sector agriculture construction is very
good I mean the way the peace comes the
whole the whole our lives are getting
better our life Thunder will be improved
I will increase my education not on me
at all so the whole rap legend so I'm
very happy to optimistic you know
through the investment that everything
is going to be improved the war took a
heavy toll here in two years of conflict
from 1998 almost a hundred thousand
people were killed
to this day Eritrea has compulsory
national service a mix of military
training and development work with no
time limit Human Rights Watch says
that's one reason why twelve percent of
the population has fled the country
which is one of the poorest in the world
the peace agreement brings a completely
new situation for the government of
Eritrea up until now the entire policy
of the country was based on the danger
of yet another war president is a Asaf
wacky is a former freedom fighter he's
ruled the country since independence 27
years ago he presents himself as a
modest man opposed to corrupt
politicians but he's been accused of
human rights violations his country has
never held elections has no constitution
no official budget and zero press
freedom will peace bring reform the
information Minister is cautious very
difficult to talk about concrete policy
measures at this stage we can only say
that okay this is it's a new situation
now and whatever was a consequence of
the war would have to be revised
very clear give the government some time
it's a transition from a situation of
almost continuous war to any situation
of peace let's not have it waiting is
something Eritrea's political prisoners
have plenty of experience with the
journalists am tahai has spent the last
17 years in jail his niece Vanessa
Bertha lives in London and is fighting
for his release if you look at what the
Eritrean government has said for the
past 70 years they have been talking
about this the situation with Eritrea as
an excuse for the for the status quo and
obviously if this you know the excuse is
gone there is space for optimism because
that means that the excuse is the thing
that's been holding the country together
in terms of participation ship has
fallen apart which is called for
optimism but if you look at the actual
practicality of situation nothing has
changed which means that realistically
one month two months three months after
the peace being declared its there's no
reason of domestic anymore only reason
to be critical on the streets of azmera
no one is prepared to speak on camera
against the government but privately
many here say they're desperate for
change